When I was asked to do a presentation on ‘Where
WebWare is going, and what I can do to help
it get there,’ my first thought was simple:
me!
As you’ve already seen, I’ve got a lot
of skills, and the right kind of personality
needed to do a job like this...
Here’s a slide I made!
You see that – that’s my sales team – they
love me!
Certainly going to be sad to see me leave...
Outside the box thinking – that’s what
I’ve got...!
Ok.
To start with, I did a careful SWOT analysis
using the data I had available, which is obviously
only partial.
I looked at aspects such as competitors, online
visibility, changing technologies and R&D...
On the basis of this, I believe WebWare should
carry out some careful market research, strengthen
its brand awareness in secondary markets,
and improve the flexibility of its offer.
If this produces positive results, I think
it should be possible to maintain the premium
pricing policy...
Here’s the sales figures for the last job
I did – all down to me!
Blue sky thinking!
Finally, to finish my presentation, I’d
like to play you a song I wrote...
Ok, Ok... that’s enough.
Thanks Daniel...
Great!
So does that mean I’ve got the job?
Erm, we’ll be in touch over the next five
days to let you know...
OK great, thank you.
This is how I’d predict a sales pattern
would go.
I have to emphasise these are only speculative
results at the moment.
The key words are: caution, adaptability,
and consolidation of main product lines – WebWare’s
“cash cows,” if you like.
It’s important to be flexible, yet reliable.
Oh, and another thing is you need to improve
the delivery times on your online orders!
I hope all that’s clear.
Do you have any questions?
No, thank you Sarah – that’s all very
clear – you’ve given us quite a lot to
think about there!
Yes, thanks a lot Sarah.
We’ll be in touch over the next few days
to let you know about the appointment.
Thank you both for your time.
It’s been a pleasure meeting both of you.
Bye!